ever since I first stepped through the
door behind Prime Minister I have
striven to make the United Kingdom a
country that works not just for a
privileged few but for everyone and to
honor the results of the EU referendum
back in 2016 we gave the British people
a choice against all predictions the
British people voted to leave the
European Union I feel as certain today
as I did three years ago that in a
democracy if you give people a choice
you have a duty to implement what they
decide I have done my best to do that I
negotiated the terms of our exit and a
new relationship with our closest
neighbors that protects jobs our
security and our union I have done
everything I can to convince MPs to back
that deal sadly I have not been able to
do so I tried three times I believe it
was right to persevere even when the
odds against success seemed high but it
is now clear to me that is it it is in
the best interests of the country for a
new prime minister to lead that effort
so I am today announcing that I will
resign as leader of the conservative and
unionist party on Friday the 7th of June
so that a successor can be chosen I've
agreed with the party chairman and with
the chairman of the 1922 committee that
the process for electing a new leader
should begin in the following week I
have kept her Majesty the Queen fully
informed of my intentions and I will
continue to serve as her prime minister
until the process has concluded it is
and will always remain a matter of deep
regret to me that I have not been able
to deliver brexit it will be for my
successor to seek a way forward that
honors the result of the referendum to
succeed he or she will have to find
consensus in Parliament where I have not
such a consensus can only be reached if
those on all side
of the debate are willing to compromise
for many years the great humanitarians
and Nicholas Winton who saved the lives
of hundreds of children by arranging
their evacuation from Nazi occupied
Czechoslovakia through the
Kindertransport was my constituent in
Maidenhead at another time of political
controversy a few years before his death
he took me to one side at a local event
and gave me a piece of advice
he said never forget that compromise is
not a dirty word life depends on
compromise he was right as we strive to
find the compromises we need in our
politics whether to deliver brexit or to
restore devolved government in northern
ireland we must remember what brought us
here because the referendum was not just
a call to leave the EU but for profound
change in our country a call to make the
United Kingdom a country that truly
works for everyone
I'm proud of the progress we have made
over the last three years we have
completed the work that David Cameron
and George Osborne started the deficit
is almost eliminated our national debt
is falling and we are bringing an end to
austerity my focus has been on ensuring
that the good jobs of the future will be
created in communities across the whole
country not just in London and the
southeast through our modern industrial
strategy we have helped more people than
ever
enjoy the security of a job we are
building more homes and helping
first-time buyers onto the housing
ladder so young people can enjoy the
opportunities their parents did and we
are protecting the environment
eliminating plastic waste tackling
climate change and improving air quality
this is what a decent moderate and
patriotic Conservative government on the
common ground of British politics can
achieve even as we tackle the biggest
peacetime challenge any government has
faced
I know that the Conservative Party can
renew itself in the years ahead that we
can deliver brexit and serve the British
people with policies inspired by our
values security freedom and opportunity
those values have guided me throughout
my career but the unique privilege of
this office is to use this platform to
give a voice to the voiceless to fight
the burning in justices that still scar
our society that is why I put proper
funding for mental health at the heart
of our NHS long term plan
it's why I'm ending the postcode lottery
for survivors of domestic abuse it is
why the race disparity audit and gender
pay reporting are shining a light on
inequality so it has nowhere to hide and
it is why I set up the independent
public inquiry into the tragedy at
Grenville tower to search for the truth
so nothing like it can ever happen again
and so the people who lost their lives
that night are never forgotten because
this country is a union not just a
family of four nations but a union of
people all of us whatever our background
the color of our skin or who we love we
stand together and together we have a
great future our politics may be under
strain but there is so much that is good
about this country so much to be proud
of so much to be optimistic about I will
shortly leave the job that it has been
the honor of my life to hold the second
female prime minister but certainly not
the last I do so with no ill will but
with enormous and enduring gratitude to
have had the opportunity to serve the
country I love
[Music]